i know you're coming up on eight years
of marriage
totally you're just the coolest couple
how have you managed to stay such a
strong unit and really prioritize your
marriage when there is so much happening
around you honestly i think at the core
of it we're truly just we're truly best
friends you know and we we really get
each other on it on a deeper level so
when there's a lot going on and and he's
on tour and i'm busy and the kids and
stuff we always
we have so much fun together that we
always want to be together so we make
that happen i think we've set a pretty
high standard for us as a couple
individual the two of us aside from the
kids and family and all of that to
really just make sure we're good and one
if we're good the kids are good our
families are good so we're just a good
team i don't know what this is like we
are you are a great team and and you
know i i follow you on instagram and it
looked like adam got up and started
singing a little bit at the wedding that
you did
your caption on that video was baby
daddy it felt to me like you were just
kind of in awe of of your god
i am always i'm always in awe of like
the power you have on stage with your
fans and
how beautiful it is you know so i'm
always looking at him and i'm like wow
i did well
so
i did well it's such a beautiful like
god-given talent when you it's like the
voiceless it really looks like it is
yeah and i i don't know if he sings
around the house but i imagine the
lullabies are pretty lit over at the
levine residence he is really good i
mean he's such a good songwriter that he
will make songs up for the girls at
night like at night time like
lullabies but it's random and all over
the place and then they want me to do it
and i'm like i don't know the song your
dad made up for you
you know and then i try and
dusty especially our oldest one is like
it's not like doesn't go like that it's
not like that
you bring up your beautiful girls dusty
rose geo grace what is it like watching
them grow up what are their little
personalities like it's amazing watching
them grow up jessie's very much adam
she's more a little bit more serious
very into music very into like very
sporty too she loves to you know her dad
takes her to play tennis or like when he
goes golfing she's there geo is me jio
is a a loose cannon she is really funny
and her
her timing much better than my community
timing and she's three she just cracks
you up and she is so wild dusty is very
she decides what she wants to wear she
wants to wear it it's always a fight in
the morning about school geo
whatever put her in anything she's
always in a cowboy boot and like
underwear you know running through the
house she's out the door no it's just a
fun time
and kind of unpredictable is dusty
showing signs of maybe wanting to follow
in the musician footsteps do you think
geo is a future supermodel
[Laughter]
can you imagine
um is very tall but they're both very
tall but geo is as tall as dusty and
she's three and desi is five the
funniest thing is they would only listen
to maroon five we have like dance
parties at the house after dinner and
it's only maroon 5 and adam would sit
there he's like can we please just
listen to something else for one
dance party and they're like now
lucky strike
is it torture for adam to have to listen
to that at home on a loop you know i
think
when you see your own kids
singing back the music that you that you
wrote like even like songs about jane 20
years ago and
they're singing it like she will be
loved in this love and and sunday
morning
it definitely gets
gets his heart strings going do your
kids think you guys are cool do they
understand how fame works we took them
to a show in in new york when adam was
just on tour now and dusty asked the
sweetest question she said do you know
everyone that came like thinking that
that's all adam's friends
oh answer that adam we just laughed we
were like no
maybe they think every
everyone's dad sings they watch paw
patrol every day and they're like daddy
singing in paw patrol they must think
like the other guy singing is maybe her
best friend at school's dad
i saw the interview that adam did with
howard stern earlier this year totally
cracked me up when howard said do you
think your family's complete adam's
response was something like i think my
wife would punch me in the face i asked
her for another kid
what did you make of that and what's the
answer there do you think that you might
want to expand your family more
you know what we had them he said that
because we had the girls so back-to-back
and geo was planned but
came earlier than expected basically so
we always knew we wanted a second one so
i think for me in those
two years when i had like two babies
under the age of two i was just like
don't even think about it but i do want
also want like five kids but don't even
think about it
you know what never say never
we want a big family who knows we're
leaving it up to you know
fate just seeing them together i'm like
maybe we should have a third just to you
know
have more kids
because it was so sweet to see but then
i don't know i don't know
never say never of course and i mean
look of course you just want a healthy
baby at the end of the day do you and
adam ever talk about wanting to add a
little boy maybe into the equation i
mean all the time well obviously a
healthy baby we don't care but um
i always thought i was only gonna have
boys and then adam came along and we
only had girls
and
it's honestly amazing i i wouldn't trade
it for the world i think adam is such a
girl dad too like he
he just is so good with him they love
him so much
and he honestly at this point
keeps telling me he's like i don't think
i would know what to do with a boy like
i was i'm a boy obviously and i was a
teenage boy and he's like i don't know
if i know what to do with that
we watch the laker game we make a drink
and then we hang out there and it's just
really nice this is for the grown-ups
growing up yeah
cali rosa i like to call it your third
baby i know
i'm like
how did you beat prince lou get into the
tequila business me and adam
are huge tequila drinkers we love
tequila we love red wine when we found
out that the two can be blended into one
we were kind of like this is a
no-brainer for us it kind of just
was born out of our love for tequila our
love for mexico the culture we got
married there adam threw my 30th
surprise birthday party there his 40th
was i mean we love it and that's kind of
how this whole dream started okay
tonight with biati and adam drinking
tequila what goes down
so much
we were watching um succession huge
succession fans
so when the kids are in bed and we had
our dinner we make you know we make our
drink adam likes it neat with a slice of
orange i love the inejo and i will drink
it on the rocks with a slice of orange
getting into business with your
significant other it can be dicey for
some couples what has that experience
been like for you and adam mixing the
business with the pleasure it's honestly
been really fun for us i think we've
always wanted to do something together
the great thing about us is and adam
especially i think he's such a creative
person and he really listens
to because he's in a band so there's so
many people that give it's give and take
right so he created that where when i'm
not totally into something he's like
okay how do you want how should we make
it better and if i'm wrong i'm usually
the first to admit i am wrong and he's
always right
so we really we we're good together we
have fun
[Music]
you